PROFESSOR ROBERT SHILLER:
All right.
Well, we're talking about
institutional investors today.
I don't know, if that sounds
like an enticing topic to you.
''Institutional'' sounds boring,
but I'm actually
talking about people, who
control much of the wealth of
the world, and they have a lot
of influence and importance.
So, I think it's worth
considering them, and
considering it's really
part of the
governance of the world.
How do things happen?
Who decides what is
going to happen?
What's going to be done?
Increasingly, it
is professional
institutional investors.
They're kind of unseen,
mostly.
They don't make movies about
them, not that I've ever seen.
Someone tell me, if
there is one.
But they're very important.
So, I thought I would start
by just talking about the
importance of --
in this lecture I'm going to
include both people, who
manage money for institutional
portfolios, and also financial
advisors and financial
planners.
They're a very big and
important part
of the world economy.
But I wanted to start by just
giving some perspective on
them, by looking at what
it is that we own,
and what they manage.
So, I thought I would start
for the United States, and
show a list of everything,
everything that's owned.
And I got this from --
this is from Table B-100 of
the Balance Sheet for the
American Economy [addition: as
of the fourth quarter of
2010], produced by the Federal
Reserve Board in Washington.
So, it's really a sum of
everything, everything that
people own in the
United States.
And the point I'm going to
make from this is, that
institutional investors are
quite prominent on this list,
as managers of it.
But let's just first
look at the total.
This is $70,740 billion, or
let's say, $70 trillion is it.
It's everything that anyone owns
in terms of assets that
the Fed can measure.
Of course, there's all
these priceless
things that we all own.
They are not on this list.
So, what are they?
Well, number one
is real estate.
This is owned by households.
Actually, they lump in
nonprofits, unfortunately,
because nonprofit organizations
are like people,
because nobody owns them.
So, this is the sum of
everything that ultimate
owners own, so it's
everything.
But nonprofits are a small
part of the total.
So, real estate is
$18 trillion.
That's real estate owned
directly by households and
nonprofits.
It doesn't include commercial
real estate that is owned by
some of these other things.
But that's not held by
institutions, that's held
directly by households.
But the next item on this thing
is pension funds, and
that's $13 trillion.
Almost as big as real estate.
And what are pension funds?
These are plans, that either
businesses create for their
employees, or that people
invest in themselves for
retirement.
It's planning for old age.
Then, there's equity in
non-corporate business.
Non-corporate business means
family businesses.
Well, not necessarily family,
but partnerships and family
businesses.
You know, the corner store is a
business, it's worth something.
The Fed has estimated the total
value of all of these
non-corporate businesses, and
estimates them at $6 trillion.
Again, that's not
institutionally held, that's
held by families and people.
So far, we've got more family
than institutional.
But then, as you keep going down
the list, deposits are
deposits at banks.
$8 trillion.
That's savings deposits,
time deposits.
Now, that's institutional
investors managing that.
Corporate equities, now this
is shares in corporations,
owned by households.
That's $8 trillion.
Now, we're back to households
owning them directly.
But then, we have
mutual funds.
Mutual funds are investment
funds for the general public,
that invest in equities
and sometimes
bonds and other things.
And that's almost $5 trillion.
Consumer durables.
We're going kind of -- seems
like half and half or maybe a
little bit less than half are
institutional, but it's a big
share so far.
Consumer durables, about
$5 trillion.
That's your cars, your clothes
that you're wearing, whatever
else is in your house.
It's estimated at $5 trillion.
Treasury securities are --
now, that's government bonds.
It might surprise you that
it's only $1 trillion.
That includes both savings
bonds, which your
grandmother gave you.
I don't know if you
got that --
you got a $100 saving bonds --
maybe you did.
But that's only $100, doesn't
add up to much.
There are big-time treasury
securities that are treasury
bonds, treasury notes, but they
generally are held by
institutions, not -- households
just generally
don't buy them.
The total national debt is now
-- in the United States it's
$14 trillion [addition:
approximately, as of April 11,
2011], but only $1 trillion,
that's only 1/14 of it, is
held by households.
So, the institutions hold the
rest. Well, foreigners hold
some of the rest, too,
but we're not
counting foreigners here.
Corporate bonds held directly
by households, $2 trillion.
Municipal bonds held by
households, $1 trillion.
But I'll come to this -- the
total municipal bonds
outstanding are more
like $3 trillion.
So, households don't hold them
generally, except indirectly
through institutions.
Life insurance.
These are reserves at life
insurance institutions.
That would be institutional
investors again.
So, it seems like less than
half, but close to half of all
of the assets in this
country are held by
institutional investors.
This is a change from
100 years ago.
100 years ago, virtually none
of it would be held by
institutional investors, so our
society is becoming more
institutionalized, more and more
things are being done by
professionals.
And a related thing I wanted to
mention again is that, as
society gets more modern, the
importance of the family is
diminished and the importance
of government
and business is increased.
So for example, pension funds
are taking over what used to
be a family responsibility.
When Grandma and Grandpa get
old, they move into your house
and you take care of them.
That's an extra-financial thing
that has gone on from
time immemorial.
But now, it works differently.
Grandpa and Grandma commit
to a pension fund,
contribute to it.
When they get old, they move
to an assisted living
facility, which is a place where
maybe they're happier.
I don't know.
At least they can choose.
They don't have just the single
choice of living with
you, which they might
not like.
They might like it, they might
not, but it's working more
institutionally.
So, this is really --
I wanted to talk about thoughts,
about where our
society is going, and seeing
the increasing
professionalization of it.
I thought to complete this
list I should --
remember, the previous
slide --
this $70 trillion is assets
owned by the households.
But I just wanted to get
you in the right
perspective on this.
What about liabilities?
So, the Federal Reserve Board
computes that, too.
[addition: The data is as of the
fourth quarter of 2010.]
Those assets are owned, but
it's not net worth of
households, because the
households owe money, too.
So, the biggest debt that
households owe is, in the
United States, $10 trillion
of home mortgages.
We saw they have $18 trillion
of real estate, but they owe
$10 trillion, so that they
have a net worth in real
estate of only $8 trillion.
But moreover, consumer credit
is $2.4 trillion.
That's credit card debt and some
other revolving debt like
department store cards, or
when you buy something --
when you buy a car on time, it
would go into that total.
So, the total liabilities
are $13.9 trillion.
And then, so household net
worth is the $70 trillion
assets minus the almost $14
trillion liabilities.
So, it's $56.8 trillion
is the total assets.
And in per capita terms,
that's $184,000.
That would mean that the average
family of four has
about $800,000 --
I'm just multiplying
it, 184 by 4.
That's almost $800,000,
so we're a country of
millionaires, I guess.
Or soon to be.
But the problem is it's not
-- it's only on average.
This is unequally distributed.
But I should also add, the U.S.
government has a debt of,
as of this morning
[addition: April 11, 2011]
--
I looked it up on a national
debt clock --
$14.286 trillion.
And that's not counted as a
liability of households.
But it should be, because we
have to pay it, and we're
going to pay it through
our taxes, eventually.
So, you might subtract off
another $14 trillion from the
$56 trillion.
And then, let's not forget,
there's state and local
government debt, which is
another $3 trillion [addition:
approximately, as of
April 11, 2011].
So, what does that
bring us down to?
Something like $40
trillion or less.
I wanted to do that just to get
perspective on what our
assets and liabilities
look like.
The other thing is --
I'm trying to put things in
complete perspective, so I
wanted to talk also about
something that's not on any of
this, and that's
human capital.
Human capital is the value of
our people, and what people
can do and produce.
And if you want to develop total
national wealth, you
would want to include human
capital as well.
So, what is the national wealth
for the United States,
if we include everything?
Well, the way I figured that
is, right now the national
income, U.S. national income
is $13 trillion a year
[addition: as of 2010].
And I want to capitalize
that, to value their
present value with that.
If you assume 3% growth in real
terms and a 5% discount
rate, that would make wealth
equal to $13 trillion --
I'm using the Gordon
formula --
divided by 0.05 minus 0.03,
or $260 trillion.
That's also just for
perspective, because I just
wanted to put this $40 or $50
trillion in perspective.
I'm kind of diminishing
my lecture.
I'm telling you institutional
investors are important, but
as a fraction of the total
national wealth,
it's not that important.
And I think the family is still
very important, as a
manager of our wealth.
This is not managed by
institutional investors.
One more calculation that will
diminish the importance of
institutional investors
even more.
What do you think the
world is worth?
If we were to take the total
national income of the whole
world, and take the present
value of that, well, according
to the International Monetary
Fund in Washington, which
estimates for the world, world
national income in 2010, well,
world income --
actually, this is world GDP, I
believe, but I'll use that as
a proxy for income --
is $62 trillion.
And if I use the same discount
rate and assumed growth rates,
you know what I get for the
value of the world?
World wealth?
It's $1.2 quadrillion.
Again, to put things in
perspective, we are going
through an enormous transition
in the world.
I'm only assuming a 3% growth
rate for the world, and many
countries are growing at 7% to
9% now, so maybe this is
conservative.
But I think that, as the world
matures, as we become more and
more modern and capitalist, the
importance of the family
will remain.
It will remain important, but
it will diminish in relative
importance.
So, as time goes on, we're going
to see something like a
quadrillion dollars increasingly
managed by
institutional investors.
So that's, what I want
to talk about today.
As I was saying, in modern
society we do things
differently.
We don't expect young people to
take their parents in, to
care for them.
I mentioned that
as an example.
Is that, because we don't care
about our parents as much as
we used to?
Interesting question.
There's a lot of discussion
about that, but my general
take on it is, that most
elderly people
like to have choices.
They love their children,
but they don't want to
move in with them.
They want to have a savings,
some kind of pension, they
want to be able to choose,
how they live, with
whom they live with.
Similarly, our health care, we
used to depend on our families
to provide health care, but
it didn't work very well.
People weren't getting very
good health care.
And now, we have it all
institutionalized through
trust funds for health plans,
and benefits and the like.
This means that it's
more and more run
by investment managers.
And investment managers are
trained in modern finance and
understand risk management.
So, there's a professionalism
to all this.
The family is of limited --
even if they were smart, even
if they were brilliant as
investment managers, they're
a small unit.
And unless they were to engage
in some kind of risk sharing
agreement, they can't
manage risk well.
The whole family is too small
a unit to manage risk.
But increasingly, investment
managers are running risk
management for families,
that allows risk
sharing around the world.
We have growing pains
with this.
The recent financial crisis
shows that investment managers
mess up sometimes, and their
attempt to share risks around
the world --
like, for example, the subprime
crisis was caused by
the failure to manage mortgage
risk appropriately.
But nonetheless, I think
they're getting more
professional and
more important.
So, right now we have
professional risk managers
that are, I think, increasingly
important in our
very lives.
Now, they have a
fiduciary duty.
If you are managing other
people's money --
that's a quote -- ''other
people's money,'' then you
might be negligent.
It's not my money,
what do I care?
So, the law prescribes that you,
as an investment manager,
have a duty to act in the
interest of the person you're
managing for, or the group of
people you're managing for.
And the law has been trying to
prescribe what this duty is.
There's something called the
''prudent person rule,'' which
is a rule that investment
managers have to behave as a
prudent person would.
I'll read one definition
of it.
ERISA, which was an act of
Congress in 1974, defined --
they called it ''prudent man
rule'' back then, because our
language was still
sexist in 1974 --
they said that ''investment
managers running pension funds
must manage with the care,
skill, prudence, and diligence
under the circumstances then
prevailing, that a prudent man
acting in a like capacity and
familiar with such matters
would use in the conduct of an
enterprise of a like character
and with like aims."
They're trying to legislate
what it is
to be a good fiduciary.
And it seems sensible.
You should ask -- if someone is
managing a pension fund for
elderly people, they shouldn't
do wild and crazy investments.
They shouldn't invest
in racehorses or
something like that.
It should be prudent.
But then, how do
you define it?
If you read the act, it says,
they would be acting like a
prudent man ''in a like capacity
in a conduct in an
enterprise of a like character
and was like aims."
The problem is, with the 1974
act, that it's hard to
legislate duty, define
what it is.
So, what the law said, and it
has said it in many places, is
that you have to -- as
a fiduciary, as an
investment manager --
you have to act as a prudent
person would act.
And what is a prudent person?
I guess, it's somebody else.
Somebody else, who
is of a kind of a
standard or ordinary type.
I don't know what it is.
I mean, I could say that
investing in racehorses is the
smartest thing for me to do, but
I can't claim that that's
a prudent person act.
So, the law has required
institutional investors to
some extent to behave, not as
they would behave, but as they
think other people would behave.
It was legislating a
requirement, that you don't do
what you think is smart, you
do what you think other
people think is smart.
And this has been a problem,
because what it has done is,
it has created a class of
institutional investors, who
live in fear of laws that could
come down on them, if
they, with the best of
intentions, invest on behalf
of their clients in an
unconventional way, and
therefore could be punished
for violating the prudent
person rule.
Thus, for example, because of
the prudent person rule,
university endowments, which
are an example of
institutional investments, for
much of the 20th century were
invested in bonds, government
bonds, because they thought,
well, that's prudent.
No one can tell me that
we're not prudent.
The government bond is safe.
But some investment portfolios,
notably
the one that --
we had David Swensen come and
speak to us earlier --
took a more aggressive
interpretation of the prudent
person rule, and developed an
investment strategy that
looked imprudent.
So for example, Yale University
was investing in
startup dot-com firms during
the dot-com explosion --
managed to sell out
just at the peak.
Is that being a prudent
person?
Well, the interpretation of the
prudent person rule has
changed, and this is part
of the phenomenon
that drove the bubble.
Institutional investors,
led by people like
David Swensen --
it lead to a more benign
interpretation of the prudent
person rule, and allowed
them to take chances.
And I think that, that general
sense that one could be more
aggressive in investing, was
part of the bubble that led to
the financial crisis.
I'm not saying it's a bad
thing in itself, but I'm
telling you it was part
of the factors
that led to this bubble.
I looked through Dodd-Frank.
The Dodd-Frank Act of 2010 is
the most important piece of
financial legislation in the
United States since the Great
Depression.
And I did a search for
prudent person --
it appears nowhere.
But I found that the word
prudential standards appeared
34 times in the Dodd-Frank
Act.
So, it seems like the financial
crisis is changing
things a little bit.
It's bringing our society to
want regulators, government
regulators, to be making the
ultimate decisions about what
kind of risks institutional
investors will take on.
They're still letting households
do what they want,
but in terms of institutional
investors, the Dodd-Frank Act
talks extensively about
regulators going in and
regulating what institutional
investors --
what kinds of risk
they can take.
The same thing is true
in other countries.
I think, this is a
world phenomenon.
The problem is that the prudent
person rule didn't
seem to work, didn't seem
to work well enough.
It started out, when it was
first imposed, as encouraging
a very conservative investment,
but then people
thought, as time went on, that
that didn't make sense, they
got more loose, and it let
to a financial crisis.
So, Dodd-Frank is creating
something called the FSOC, the
Financial Stability Oversight
Commission, which
has to enforce --
well, it doesn't enforce, but
it makes recommendations on
prudential standards,
particularly regarding --
well, I wouldn't say
particularly --
but including leverage.
Leverage --
we talked about it --
it's a measure of the risk that
you've imposed on your
portfolio by borrowing
to buy assets.
The economy became increasingly
leveraged up
until the financial crisis,
when it began around 2007.
And people were concerned
about that.
Well, were institutions
following the
prudent person rule?
Well, somehow, as time went on,
their mind allowed more
and more leverage to be
considered acceptable.
So, now what we have in the
Dodd-Frank Act is, that the
Financial Services Oversight
Commission is supposed to
recommend standards of leverage
and prudential
standards for financial
corporations, and to put
financial corporations under
increasing regulatory
authority to meet
those standards.
So, in some sense, it's shifted
to the government.
We had seen a historic shift of
power over investments from
individual investors to
institutional investors, and
to some extent, at least, it's
shifting to the government.
And I think --
I'm talking mostly about the
U.S., but I think this is a
currently worldwide trend.
It's exemplified also --
I mentioned before, that we had
private organizations, the
securities rating agencies such
as Moody's and Standard &
Poor's and Fitch, but the
governments are trusting them
less, and they're putting
standards more on government
regulators now.
I said I would talk about
financial advisors.
Financial advisors are people,
who don't directly manage
portfolios, they're not
institutional investors, but
they give advice to
those who do.
And the financial advisors are
regulated by governments in
most countries.
So in the U.S., for example,
the SEC, the Securities and
Exchange Commission, requires
advisors to be approved by
FINRA, to win FINRA approval,
where FINRA is the successor
to the National Association
of Securities Dealers.
It's a non-government
organization that administers
an examination and education
program for advisors.
And so, you effectively have
to go through FINRA to get
licensed to be a financial
advisor.
I'll give you an example
of an organization
of financial advisors.
NAPFA is the National
Association of Personal
Financial Advisors, that manages
the relation between
financial advisors
and the public.
These people will typically
charge between $75 and $300 an
hour, and you can get
one tomorrow.
Just make a phone call, get on
to a website, NAPFA website,
and hire one.
And they have a code
of standards.
They have to be licensed through
the SEC, and they have
to have an oath of
loyalty to the
client that they undertake.
This is a big business.
I mention it, because in one
of my first lectures I gave
you a count of how many
people there are.
But I'm just trying to --
There's also something else
called a financial planner.
Financial planners.
Now that sounds like the same
thing to me, but somehow, if
you call yourself a financial
planner, you don't have to go
through this licensing.
And in the Dodd-Frank Act,
I didn't find much new
legislation regarding them.
The Dodd-Frank Act is
calling for a study
of financial planners.
The question is, how does the
government get involved in
making these people
give good advice?
The problem is, that the
financial crisis seems to be
led by a lot of bad
advice given out.
A lot of people were encouraged
to leverage up
their ownership in their home,
to borrow heavily to buy
second homes.
I'm sure, that financial
advisors were not uniformly
advising that, or financial
planners, but there's a
concern now about what kind of
advice people were given.
So in 1996, Congress passed a
bill in the United States,
saying that financial advisors
cannot be convicted felons,
among other things.
But there hadn't been, until
then, such a law.
We have something else called
mortgage brokers.
It's a little different.
These are people, who
give advice on
getting a home mortgage.
There was no licensing of them
until the financial crisis.
Because mortgage brokers
could be anything.
They could even be a convicted
felon, until just a few years
ago, until after the crisis.
Here's the fundamental
problem, that
people are getting --
they're confronted by an
increasingly complicated
financial structure.
Living is less family, and
it's more investing and
getting involved in financial
markets, and most people don't
know how to do it.
And that the people, who give
them advice often, are not
giving them the best advice.
What can we do about that?
Well, the government is trying,
but it's imperfect.
I think that, as the world
develops, I think we'll
probably see --
I think there is a trend
toward increasing the
professionalization
of these groups.
And although it's not a simple
matter to straighten out some
of the irregularities, we're
moving, as the world gets
better and better, to even
stronger such institutions.
Now, I wanted to go through
some kinds of
institutional investing.
The mutual fund is --
I've talked about
this before --
is an investment company that
is owned mutually by the
participants.
It will invest typically in
stocks, and it distributes
everything to the owners of the
stock [correction: owners
of the fund].
The first mutual fund was the
Massachusetts Investor Trust.
That's not the university.
Massachusetts --
I'm sorry --
Investment Trust, which was
founded in the 1920s.
And it was very open and direct
with its investors.
It published its portfolio.
It promised --
it was completely open
about what it did --
and it promised nothing more
than it would divide up all of
the returns among the
participants.
There were no senior members,
who got more of the money than
anyone else.
So, MIT became a model
for an investment
fund for the public.
In the 1920s, there were many
investment funds that were
exploitative of the public.
They had two classes of
investors, and the first class
of investors ran off with the
money, at the expense of
everyone else.
So, it took a while after the
1929 crash, but the Investment
Company Act of 1940 set
the stage for the
growth of mutual funds.
And so, mutual funds are
designed for individuals, and
they are --
this is U.S. --
they are a very successful
institution.
So, you know exactly what --
they have regular reports -- you
know exactly what they're
doing, and there's no rich
person benefiting excessively
from what happens.
In Europe, they have an
analogous institution, UCITS.
It refers to a European Union
directive, called the
Undertaking for Collective
Investment and Transferable
Securities, which is an
EU directive, 1985
[clarification: In 1985, it
was still the European
Communities, and not yet the EU,
which was not established
until 1993.], and then they had
revisions in 2001, that
creates a standard investment
fund like a
mutual fund for Europe.
It used to be that every
European country had its own
securities law, and it made it
difficult, because there's so
many European countries.
So, they standardized, and
they developed a sort of
European version of
the mutual fund.
The key difference, I think,
between a mutual fund in the
U.S. and a UCITS
in Europe is --
it's technical --
it's how they're taxed.
The mutual fund in the
United States --
if you own shares in a mutual
fund and you just hold them,
you will still get capital gains
taxes every year, even
if you didn't sell it.
Because other people in the
mutual fund sell some of their
shares, generating a capital
gains, and that capital gains
is then distributed to all
of the participants
in the mutual fund.
With a UCITS in Europe, you
don't pay capital gains taxes,
unless you yourself sell.
So, I think the UCITS
form is gaining on
the mutual fund form.
And some people, notably
Robert Pozen at Harvard
Business School is advocating
that the U.S. switch to the
European standard.
I wanted to talk about trusts.
What is a trust?
It is money held on behalf
of another individual.
Well, particularly a personal
trust is something, that you
can set up on behalf of another
person or a cause, so
that an institutional investor
will manage money on behalf of
that person or cause.
And a company that does trusts
is called a trust company, and
trust companies have often been
combined with banks, but
they're not necessarily
part of a bank.
You see many institutions and
the title will be Bank and
Trust Company.
Well, you know what
a bank does.
It takes deposits
and makes loans.
What does a trust company do?
It creates trusts on behalf of
some person and manages the
money for them.
A classic example of a trust
is, imagine that you have a
child, who is handicapped in
some way and unable to manage
his or her own affairs.
And you, as a parent, know that
your child will outlive
you, and so how do you
provide for the child
after you are gone?
Well, you create a trust
for the child.
And you can go to a trust
company and say, I want an
income for my child, managed
for the rest of my child's
life, and the bank will outlive
you -- or the trust
company will outlive you
-- and can do that.
So, this is very important,
because it allows people to
create situations that
outlive them.
But particularly in common law
countries, it doesn't have to
be a company.
You can set up a trust, you can
take a young relative of
yours, who will outlive you, and
say, I want you to be the
trust manager for my child.
And if you become ill, can
you appoint a successor?
You can do that, too.
U.S. trust law recognizes the
importance of trusts, and so
that person -- suppose that
person that you appoint as a
trustee for your child, suppose
that person goes
bankrupt, and then other people
are taking, seizing,
that person's assets.
They could not take the assets
in the trust, because the law
recognizes the importance
of trusts.
There are different
kinds of trusts.
But I thought, I should tell
you about a particular kind
that may be relevant to some
of you in your future.
There's a certain kind of trust
called a ''spendthrift
trust,'' which is a trust that
your parents may be setting up
for you now.
I don't know.
What is a spendthrift?
A spendthrift is someone who
spends money to freely.
Can't be trusted to
manage money.
Suppose, you have a child, who's
like that, and you're
getting on in years, and you're
thinking that you could
leave a will to your child.
But the child might
just blow it.
So, what you do is, you go to a
trust company, and you say,
I'd like to set up a spendthrift
trust for my
child, and after I die, the
trust will pay my child an
income, and the child
cannot get at the
assets, only the income.
And so, you manage it, and the
child comes to you and says, I
want the money, and
you say, sorry.
Your parents set up a
spendthrift trust. That's all
you can get.
There's various reasons
why they do this.
One of them is, that in a
divorce, if your child gets
divorced, if you gave money to
the children, the divorce
court might give half of the
money to the awful spouse your
child married.
But if it's a spendthrift trust,
they can't get at it.
It's income to the child.
So, there's all kinds
of reasons why
people set up trusts.
But I think trusts are a really
an important invention
in our society, and they're not
talked about very much.
But I mean, it solves
a real problem.
This handicapped child problem
is an extreme case,
but it's very real.
You can have assurance, the law
makes it clear that that
money is managed by a
professional for the child.
These are real and important
institutions that help people
get on with their lives, and I
think our financial system
does a lot to make these
things work well.
I wanted to talk about
pensions because --
I've already talked about them,
but people do get old
and they can't keep working.
And if you look at the history
of the world, the fate of
elderly people is
highly variable.
Many of them, if they have good
and dutiful children,
will do all right --
who take care of them.
But in the past, you would find
a lot of elderly people
out on the streets begging,
because they didn't have
children, or the children died,
or the children lost
their income.
It's a problem that we've worked
substantially to solve,
and again, it's an example of
progress of our civilization.
We take it for granted, that
people are living as
comfortably as well as they are,
but it's substantially a
product of invention.
So, the idea of a pension
is actually a
relatively new idea.
The first U.S. pension
plan was 1875.
American Express Company
set up a pension
plan for its employees.
There's actually an earlier
example in the U.K., I think,
but I don't have the
name of it here.
But only something like
20 years earlier.
So, until then, there was
never a pension plan.
So, American Express set up a
plan, and it said employees,
who had worked at --
this, by the way, is not the
credit card company, this was
a delivery company.
They had stagecoaches.
This is a long time ago.
And if you worked there for 20
years, past age 60, and were
disabled, you would get 50% of
the average of the last 10
years pay for life.
This was the model --
50% of average of the last 10
years pay on retirement.
Because it was tied to
how much income.
They thought, you could live
on half the income that you
earned when you were working.
In 1901, Carnegie Steel --
that's Andrew Carnegie, the
same Andrew Carnegie, who
wrote The Gospel of Wealth
that we've been
talking about --
gave what was the first large
industrial pension fund.
And it covered a substantial
number of people, it was a
milestone that suggested many
more such pension funds.
Unions, in the early 20th
century, started setting up
pension funds.
For example, the Pattern Makers
in 1900, the Granite
Cutters and Cigar Makers
in 1905, et cetera.
The union pension funds became
popular in the early 20th
century, but there
was a collapse of
pensions after 1929.
Many people were promised
pensions in the first three
decades of the 20th century,
and then the companies just
went out of business
and didn't --
moreover, the unions' pension
funds failed especially
disastrously.
They didn't manage their money
well, or the institutional
investors were not
very astute.
You know, it's like the world
was very amateurish about how
they handled these things.
Obviously, it's very important
that people have money to
retire on, but many of them got
wiped out in 1929, so it
lead to further thinking
about pensions.
The General Motors pension plan
was a landmark pension
plan in 1950.
And in 1950, GM chairman Charles
Wilson proposed a
fully funded pension plan.
This was a new idea.
That is, General Motors, in
promising to pay you in your
retirement, would set aside and
invest now enough money,
so that they would have that.
In other words, they created
a trust for the employees.
So, it's just like the parent
for the handicapped child.
If General Motors dies, doesn't
matter, because
there's a trust managing
their pension fund.
You know, it's kind
of a funny idea.
Why didn't anyone
do that before?
Why didn't the unions, who were
looking out for the union
employees, demand that they
fund their pension funds?
You know, it seems like
financial history shows a lot
of stupidity.
I don't quite understand,
how it could be.
It seems obvious, doesn't it,
that if a company is going to
promise you for a pension,
that they
should set aside money?
Because companies fail
all the time.
There may have been some union
complicity, that the unions
were not really always working
on behalf of their members.
They thought, well, the members
don't think about this
problem, so we're not going
to think about it, either.
It's going to come years
down the road, we're
not going to worry.
So, General Motors, in
1950, set an example
for funding the pensions.
It's very important.
And more and more firms started
to do that after 1950.
But the next thing I want
to give is Studebaker.
Do you remember Studebaker?
They were one of the major
automobile manufacturers.
You maybe don't remember
them, because they
went bankrupt in 1963.
That's a long time ago for you,
but they were around.
Well, they had a pension plan
that was partly funded, but
inadequately funded, and, when
they went out of business,
their employees lost. So, this
led to arguments about --
and their labor union, again,
the United Autoworkers,
supposedly standing up for the
employees, didn't do the job.
So, the whole idea of labor
management negotiating,
protecting the workers seemed
flawed, and so the government
got involved, and
it led to ERISA,
which I mentioned before.
1974.
ERISA stands for Employment
Retirement
Income Security Act.
This was an act to clean up
pension funds, and make them
work well, make them
work better.
The government wanted to make
sure, not only that pension
plans said they were funded,
but that they were really
funded, so that another
bankruptcy wouldn't cause
pension plans to fail.
So, ERISA set up a new
government agency, called the
Pension Benefits Guarantee
Corporation.
That's PBGC.
The Pension Benefits Guarantee
Corporation is a government
organization that insures the
funding of pension plans.
So, pension plans not only have
to undergo scrutiny by
the PBGC that they are fully
funded, but they also have to
pay an insurance premium
to the PBGC.
And if it turns out that they're
not fully funded, then
the PBGC will come in and
replace the lost income.
You see, over the century we're
trying to come up with
financial structures that solve
basic human problems.
The PBGC, by the way, is still
here, and it hasn't gone
bankrupt, despite this
financial crisis.
Though people were worried
about it, it
has managed to survive.
After 1974 --
shortly after this --
after 1974, a new kind of
pension plan became popular.
So, ERISA was written in an age
of defined benefit pension
plans, like the original
American Express pension plan.
What did American Express
pension plan in
1875 promise you?
It promised you half of
your average income
for the last 10 years.
And if you're going to fund
the pension plan, you're
presenting a problem to the
managers of the pension money.
They have to hit that target.
They're told, the pension plan
has an obligation to fund the
payments equal to whatever
percent of last year's income.
And that's kind of a tricky
problem, if you're a manager.
How do I do that?
How do I hit that target?
How do I know, how much
money to set aside?
Well, it's getting now into
government regulators, and
prudent person rules,
and it's tricky.
But the point is that in 1974,
almost all pension
plans were like that.
They defined the benefit
that you would
receive when you retired.
But afterwards, in the 1980s,
companies started offering a
new kind of pension plan, called
a defined contribution.
The idea was, it's hard for us
to hit that target, of say 50%
of your average income for
the last 10 years.
How do you expect
us to do that?
We don't know, how much these
investments will pay out.
We don't even know, how much
money you'll be paid in your
last 10 years.
So, it's asking us to
do the impossible.
Well, it's not impossible,
but it is difficult.
So, many companies decided,
instead of requiring a defined
amount to be paid, they would
just define the contribution
they'll make to your
portfolio.
They give you a portfolio as
an employee, and you get
whatever income that portfolio
generates when you retire.
The most famous example of that
is a 401(k) plan in the
United States.
But ever since, shortly after
ERISA, the world has been
moving towards defined
contribution pension plans,
where a defined contribution
pension plan doesn't promise
what you'll get in retirement.
So then, a portfolio manager
for a defined contribution
pension plan doesn't have to
worry about hitting targets.
And in fact, the way defined
contribution plans are usually
set up, they give the individual
employee the choice
of the main portfolio allocation
between stocks and
bonds and real estate,
or whatever.
But you have investment managers
managing within one
of those asset classes.
So, there will be someone
managing an equity fund,
another one managing a bond
fund, and they try to do as
well as they can as investors,
subject to the restriction of
what they invest in, and it's
left to the client to choose
the allocation.
Defined contribution plans
are going through
growing pains, too.
We still don't have the
perfect system.
The problem with defined
contribution plans --
one problem is, that you don't
have to sign up for them, the
way they've been set up.
It used to be, under the old
days, defined benefit plans,
it was just automatically, every
employee would get the
pension plan.
But with a defined contribution
plan, the typical
rule was, that the company
would ask you to make
contributions out of your
paycheck to the plan, and the
company with then match them,
typically, with additional
contributions.
But something like a quarter of
the people would choose not
to participate --
that's, because they're not
thinking, they're not
thinking ahead --
and so, when they come to
retire, they don't have any
pension plan.
Moreover, some of them
take the most
risky investment offered.
They might put it all in the
stock market, and if the stock
market does badly, they might
end up poor in retirement.
And companies generally would
not give any advice to the
people, who were employees,
because they didn't want to be
liable for giving bad advice.
So, it led to kind
of an amateur
investing for pension plans.
So, there has been work to try
to fix that, and I think
federal legislation has made
it easier for companies to
give advice to employees.
They've also allowed, recently,
in the last few
years, for companies to
automatically enroll employees
in a pension plan, and allow
them to make allocations, if
they didn't hear anything
from the employees.
In other words, they'll put you
into a prudent allocation,
and then you're actually
there.
You're in it, because
you've said nothing.
That's working towards
solving the problem.
We still don't have, I think,
the ideal solution to any of
these things.
So, I've talked about
pension plans.
Let me move on to endowments.
Endowment managers, of which
David Swensen is one.
So, an endowment manages a
portfolio for some cause or
some purpose, like
a university.
And the history of endowments
is one of great --
it's just amazing to me, how
many serious mistakes were
made in history, but we're
gradually becoming more
professional.
So, I give you an example
of a mistake.
This is in Swensen's book.
In 1825, Yale University put
its entire endowment in an
investment in the Eagle
Bank of New Haven.
You know what happened?
It went to zero.
It ended up with nothing.
So, Yale had no endowment
after 1825.
So, Elihu Yale may have given
us money, and we should have
turned it into a pretty tidy
sum, compound interest from
1700 to 1825, but we
blew it completely.
This is the first thing you
learn, in a portfolio you
don't put all of your money
in one investment.
But Yale University did that.
By the way, I was looking it
up, 1825 was the year that
Yale College introduced the
economics requirement, or they
called it political economy.
Before that there were no
economics courses at Yale.
But maybe it was this experience
that made them do
that in 1825.
So, I'm going to give
you another example.
Boston University --
this is much more recent --
under John Silber, invested not
the whole endowment of the
university, but $90 million in
one company called Seragen,
which was a genetic engineering
company.
And just John Silber decided to
do this, and he lost Boston
University 90% of $90 million.
University of Bridgeport, not
far from here, blew its whole
endowment, and ended up having
to join the Unification Church
to survive.
I think that somehow that's
been undone since then.
I'm not sure of the details.
It may not have been, what they
would have done, if they
had had an endowment.
See, what Swenson thinks is,
what he's doing is protecting
the ability of a university to
undergo its financial mission.
And so, because Swenson was
not overly constrained by
prudent person rules, because
he was free to invest in a
high intellectual standard, he's
made it possible for Yale
to pursue its educational
objectives.
Right now at Yale University,
like other successful
endowment universities, graduate
students get their
whole tuition paid, plus
a living allowance.
It's like a job, coming to
be a graduate student.
The university pays --
you should know this,
if you're thinking
of getting a PhD.
Come to one of these
universities, and they'll pay
you something like $25,000
a year, something
like that to --
that's a pretty good deal.
It's not a deal, it's a gift.
It's the generosity of the
alumni, and it's the success
of the investment strategy
that makes that possible.
And then, I wanted to talk
about another kind of
institutional investor, and this
will bring me back to my
discussion of the family.
I started out by saying that the
family is the fundamental
unit of our society.
Its demise has been predicted.
Remember that in the Communist
Manifesto, Karl Marx said
we're going to end the family
as an economic unit?
Something like that.
Didn't happen.
It's too ingrained in our genes
or our long history.
So, I thought, I should come
back and talk about family
offices and family foundations,
although these
apply only to the more wealthy
people in our society.
What is a family office?
These are --
people who have $100
million or more
typically set these up.
Maybe even less.
Maybe, with $20 million
in assets.
But if you have $100 million
in assets, 5% income is $5
million a year, right?
It would be sensible to take on
some full-time employees to
manage your family portfolio,
and so that's
called a family office.
I recently spoke at a family
office forum, down in Florida.
They seemed to be
very numerous.
There's an awful lot
of families.
The families come to these
conventions, and they hear
people like me speak.
Although I'm different than most
of them, because most of
the people speaking there wanted
to sell products, and I
wasn't there to sell anything.
So, they typically have two or
three or five people working
full-time, managing their
portfolio and planning things
like trusts for the children.
And then, there's something
else called a family
foundation.
A family office is for the
family, and there's something
else called a family
foundation.
And this is different from a
family office, but they could
be interrelated, and I
think most wealthy
families have both.
A family foundation is a
charitable organization,
created by a family with the
name of the family typically
on the foundation.
I think that most wealthy
familes -- or actually, I
don't know.
A large number of wealthy
families, at least in the
United States, now set up
family foundations.
And the reason they do that --
well, why do they do that?
I think it's partly, because,
when you're wealthy, you
realize that you can't spend
it all on yourself.
And you reflect on yourself
as a member of society.
As people get older, they think,
what am I going to do
with this money?
So increasingly, people are
setting up family foundations.
I learned, that, as of 2006,
there were 36,000 family
foundations in the United
States, and
it's growing rapidly.
There seems to be a trend
toward that, I think,
reflecting our increasing
affluence, but, I think also,
reflecting maybe changing
values.
So, the typical family
foundation is not huge.
It might be $1 million
or $2 million.
So, you can set something like
that up, eventually --
not right now --
I want you to think
about doing that.
So, whatever it is you believe
in, you set up a family
foundation to do that, while
you're still young, and you
get it going, and it will
then outlive you.
And you endow it, you give it
enough -- say, you give it a
couple million dollars.
That would be a small
family foundation,
but you can do that.
And then, there's some named
cause, like it could be
improving neighborhoods in
our city or the like.
And family foundations,
I think there's an
important tax advantage.
You don't want to think about
this yet, but you should start
thinking about it.
When you start making money,
assuming that happens, what do
you do with it?
Now, you're pulling in a
million dollars a year.
That's something that
you might well do.
And so, I can just put in the
bank and not think about it?
One problem is, the government
will tax you on it.
And you get a charitable
deduction from your tax, which
encourages you to give
to charities.
All right.
So, you're now 30 years old,
and you're making a million
dollars a year.
And what do I do with
all this money?
I'm paying taxes on it.
If I give it away, I
get a tax break.
So, there's an incentive
to give away.
You're getting all these phone
calls at night from --
they found out that
you exist --
from United Fund or different
charitable organizations.
But you stopped answering the
phone, because you're annoyed
by all these phone calls, and
you're thinking, I don't want
to just give it away to
someone that called
me up on the phone.
I want to think about
what I'm --
I want to do something
for the world.
The idea is that, while you're
still young, you set up a
family foundation, and you
give the money to the
foundation irrevocably.
All right?
It has a cause written in its
charter or something.
And then, you don't have
to spend it now.
You're too busy thinking about
what you're doing, so you
start contributing to the family
foundation, and it
accumulates.
And meanwhile, you're getting
the tax deduction.
So, that's why 36,000 families
have done this in the United
States, and I think it's
growing, again,
over all the world.
Sometimes, family foundations
are plans for children, too,
because your children can
then run the foundation.
It becomes an ongoing thing
for the family that unites
them in a cause, as
time goes by.
I think, this is really
important to recognize this
channel -- although it's only
36,000, that's still
a lot of them --
as we think about the growing
inequality in the United
States and in other places
around the world, and think
about the policy toward that.
I think, we should do something
about inequality,
but I think encouraging this
kind of a family foundation
activity is a good cause.
I wanted to just
think about --
I'm almost done here --
there's a recent book by a Wall
Street Journal writer,
Robert Frank, called
Richistan.
And he talks about rich people
in America and what they do.
And the book --
this is Frank, Robert Frank --
the book talks about excess
that some people do.
Some rich people spend money
lavishly, and it disgusts
people, who think, what is
going on in our society?
But on the other side of
it, there is also this
philanthropic trend that
Frank talks about.
So, I'll give you an example.
Robert Frank talks, for example,
about Paul Allen.
Remember him?
I guess, he was the number
two man at Microsoft.
So, is he a good person?
Well, I'll give you two sides to
that story, and this I got
from Richistan.
Paul Allen wanted to have the
biggest yacht in the world,
and so he went to a
yacht company, and
had a 400-foot yacht.
It turned out, they said --
it created problems for him,
because he couldn't dock it at
any yacht club.
He had to go to industrial docks
for major cargo ships.
So, that's a big yacht, and
he called it The Octopus.
Paul Allen has a new book that
just came out, or it's just
coming out now, called
Idea Man.
In his own recount of himself,
he had brutal battles and
arguments with Bill Gates.
It was a revealing thing.
They were really in this
for the money.
So, he's starting to look
like a bad guy, right?
Because here he is showing off
with the biggest yacht
in the world --
and actually, he's been topped
by somebody else.
Who was it?
Larry Ellison got a
450-foot yacht.
But on the other side
of it is, there is
something called the --
it's the Paul G. Allen Family
Foundation, which he has set
up already.
And it turns out, he has already
donated over a billion
dollars through this
foundation and
otherwise to charity.
So, that's much bigger than
the 450-foot octopus.
What does it cost to buy
a 450-foot yacht?
I don't know, it's
not going to be a
billion dollars, right?
This is one of the ironies that
you face in living, that
someone like Paul Allen, he's
a tough businessman, an
aggressive guy, he sometimes
does extravagant expenditures,
but on the other side, there's
this charitable side, so I
think we have to reserve
judgment about most people.
Anyway, what he has working
for him is a great
understanding, apparently, of
financial arrangements, of
endowments, and he's setting
these up, and you got to give
him credit for that, and I think
we have to consider that
as important.
Institutional investing is an
important trend in our society
that can and does work for
important and good purposes.
I'll see you on Wednesday.